اتابع معكم الان هذه اللقطات المباشره
لمراسم استقبال الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زينينسكي في العاصمه
البولنديه وارسو من طرفي ناظره البولنديه
ليصل بولنديه كانت اعلنت مؤخرا تسليم
اوكرانيا عددا من الطائرات من طرازميج 29
لاول مره فضلا عن دبابات المانيات
اذا هذا هو فلاديمير رئيس الاوكراني يصل
الان الى القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه
البولنديه
ويستقبله هنا رئيس البولنديه انترنت
تاتي هذه الزياره في مرحله مهمه اليوم
ربما من تاريخ
الصراع الروسيه الاوكراني على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
وبولندا كانت قد التزمت بتقديم الدعم
العسكري والمساعدات ايضا
لاوكرانيا في حربها مع روسيا
بالاضافه كذلك الى انها من اوائل الدول
التي بادرت بتقديم
الاسلحه
والدبابات كما لونا قبل قليل لان كذلك
بانسان او بصدد ارسال مجموعه من الطائرات
من طراز 29
ودبابات كذلك
وها هو الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير
في مراسم استقباله داخل قصر
او القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه البلديه